bloomberg had another insane article
talking about how people should spend
their paychecks right away while of
course borrowing money as much as they
can at the same time to battle inflation
it's it's absolutely ridiculous policy
to have jim cramer up on national
television saying that we have the
strongest economy than we ever have ever
and then and then his
former substance abuse having self
being on the same news organization that
that is reporting record high inflation
there's there's no way you could have
both and there's obviously a huge
disconnect between reality and what the
corporate media is telling you i think
they're meant to confuse you but i think
there's also a small population that
wants to be kind of consoled by these
corporate heads and told everything's
going to be okay this inflation's great
for you it's all going to work out fine
just give up all your powers to the
bankers just give up all your
sovereignty give up all your liberty and
freedom it's all going to be one thing i
want to pull this article real quick
sure yeah just because luke referenced
it yeah bloomberg is mercilessly mocked
after advising americans to spend their
paycheck immediately and borrow lots of
money to tackle inflation in similar
advice given to economic basket case
argentina uh we're imploding yeah
they're like negotiate a pay raise or
two to get a house
how how can the average person afford a
house it's absolutely crazy uh
especially on modern wages especially
with their wages being devalued compared
to of course inflation people's savings
their whole life savings is are
absolutely being ruined right now
it's the value of the dollar is being
devalued while of course the richest
people take whatever they could get the
billionaires are more richer than they
ever have been and they're only going to
become more richer from here one thing
that you know then the last time i was
on your show was my last day at the
washington examiner i've been
independent since
that's nine months ago
and what i've learned in those nine
months is that
the corporate media
and a lot of these elites
i feel like their only purpose
is to gaslight us they're just they
solely exist
just to drive us all insane
and when you have stories like this it
sort of reaffirms that idea
that
they're telling you that the the sky is
is brown when it's clearly blue it's
just
i i don't know why and then you go on
twitter and you're like here's a picture
of the sky and then you get these
establishment new york times pundits
being telling you know far right and and
also they use it as a power play because
then they could say that person is crazy
that's why you need to give us more
power and vote for us because if you
give these people power
then you're screwed yeah and more people
are going insane if you look at mental
health there has been an absolute
downward trajectory ever since the onset
of social media that is causing uh
self-harm that is causing suicide that
is causing depression and it's causing a
huge spike in prescriptions uh by of
course big pharma that's giving off
ssris and a lot of other drugs to battle
a lot of people's negative uh health
mental health specifically that they're
uh that's only becoming more of a bigger
problem more by the day let me let me
read a little bit from this article it
says the piece takes advice from
argentinians on how they deal with
soaring inflation in a country ravaged
by 50
price rises in a typical year an extreme
increase in the cost of living is
officially called hyperinflation among
the handy tips it advises americans to
negotiate a pay raise or two and to buy
homes and cars the article has been
savaged by commentators who claim it's
hopelessly out of touch with americans
facing the highest rate of inflation in
40 years
ian miles chong wrote america is turning
into the weimar republic with financial
magazines advising people to spend their
paychecks as soon as they get them as
soon as they get paid hyperinflation is
coming
now look at this
i don't know if uh if if you can call it
hyperinflation because that's sort of
like a you know nebulous term inflation
is the word hyperinflation just means
you know a lot of it
we're dealing with a major spike in
inflation they're spending more and more
money they're printing more and more
money the m1 money stock skyrocketed
when they converted savings into
effectively to checking accounts but
it's still skyrocketing faster than
we've ever seen
i think hyperinflation is coming i think
unless there's some kind of major in
like serious conflict crisis
intervention or lockdown or something
we are going to see like hyperinflation
and that being said any kind of
intervention could only exacerbate it so
i just i don't
this mate understand on the screen right
now i have an image showing this major
spike
in the past year
and it and it tracks alongside perfectly
what we see with the m1 money supply you
see one major spike straight up and then
it curves a little bit and then goes up
at a similar rate
it's almost nice too almost at six point
nine percent oh yeah it's pretty good if
it if it was six point nine we'd be
chill about yeah yeah six point eight
i'd be okay with it but six point eight
ah
we had maxies we had max kaiser on the
show what did he say 15 percent
yeah he says that the real numbers are a
lot bigger than of course the official
numbers that are absolutely
underinflated it's kind of kind of like
unemployment i've been i've been saying
this to for a while like especially here
running the business i was like whatever
we need for the business let's not wait
let's get it now and the problem is
our attitude is based on witnessing in
real time the the ridiculousness of
inflation and the mass money spending so
you know here we're like what's our
budget we need new cameras for the new
show we need new studio equipment let's
not wait let's buy it now and then build
instead of you know building out the
hardware like building out the the set
design and then getting the equipment to
fit it no no just buy it now we'll
figure it out later because if we wait a
month or two the price is going to go up
20 to 30 50 bucks who knows could even
go up way more than that so let's spend
it now that's a problem
because if people have that mentality
and they start buying like crazy that
also sparks more inflation and makes the
spiral happen faster
downward spiral uh maybe it strikes me
as like um the horse problem early 1900s
i think you've mentioned this a few
times where so much horse manure in the
streets that they're like at this rate
the cities are going to be overridden
with horse manure what are we going to
do there's no solution in sight then all
of a sudden the car was invented the
entire problem was eradicated i think
yeah it seems like it's a similar
situation whether or not we do
create the the automobile of the economy
that we need today to solve this i don't
know but it seems like that kind of
problem well it almost seems like
financial collapse is the goal i mean
that's i mean if you think you mentioned
how how the elites obviously becoming
more becoming richer
you also have to factor in the
international
interests that say like the chinese
communist party has in basically buying
up parts of the us
more and more financial collapse only
benefits them yep and they want they're
buying land like crazy exactly and if
they can buy more of our debt they'll do
it dude it cannot be understated how how
valuable collapsing an economy is to the
rich people you make
so much money when you collapse an
economy and you're rich
yeah everyone's selling their homes so
they could afford food everyone's
renting instead of owning so that's one
aspect of it is it time to ask if biden
is an agent of china oh yeah wow china
and russia let me show you let me let me
show this tweet so president biden
tweeted the united states pays its debts
when they are due that's why today i
signed a bill to fast-track the process
to raise our debt limit to which i
responded
i remember when my parents had to use
credit cards to pay bills too yeah it's
not good good one that's not good but
it's a serious it's a serious point it
we we were never in a good position when
it was like the electric bills do what
do we do it's like a credit card put it
on the credit card
yeah it's like well then you're just
digging yourself into a deep hole it's
literally what the united states has
been doing for a very long time and he's
proud of him and he's like look how good
i am look how great i am i'm signing a
bill that's going to indebt this country
where you can't get out of financially
your children are going to have to pay
for this reckless spending that he's
trying to as he's still trying to pass
the build back better bill and and
fundamental
institutional changes that of course
will just print more money throw more
money into their climate and equity
efforts and all this other ridiculous
nonsense that they're trying to push
forward which will push for more
regulations uh more taxes more control
of government in your in your life which
i just got to say the cgi on that video
is incredible you can't even see the
strings of the people
it does look like a green screen a
little bit is that from the real white
oval office or the set
that's the that looks like the real one
yeah it's gotta be real yeah there's a
there's like across the street they have
a sound stage and it's got like tv
screens on the windows it's not real
it's been a weird past couple of years i
gotta say weird gear yeah maybe maybe
the large hadron collider you know
caused the black hole to swallow the
earth
you know like don lemon said
now we're just in this like weird
twisted reality
where our thoughts are altering where
thoughts become rally reality too much
trump is the president or was it's
possible that our thoughts are becoming
reality much faster than they used to i
don't know if there's something to them
we're just in an episode of black mirror
guys yeah
yeah that's all it is like you know you
live in a simulation we take our lives
too seriously but right now there's some
dude watching he's just eating popcorn
music
school show that's it it's that south
park episode of of earth
you know it could be everything seems
you know what's funny is like people
talk about miracles and stuff and i
remember when i was little talking
people about religion they're like when
you're older you see the signs and i was
like well i don't know about that now
i'm older and i'm like there's no way
this is real life
can't be like like joe biden as
president this is crazy everything
that's happening is just ridiculous and
stupid like everybody knows what's going
on with epstein but like nothing happens
there's like a show trial and everyone
just carries along like everyone i think
everyone just kind of pretends that that
the world isn't a
giant fireball because it's the only way
to survive to just be like i'm gonna
keep focused eat my breakfast and go
home and not worry about it got the left
to keep from crying you can only keep
your head in the sand so long until that
fire gets on your family-friendly show
on your uh buttocks and
lights a fire underneath your your
buttocks so so i i think it's only a
matter of time until people are affected
by it people are already affected by it
their lives were interrupted they were
told to stay home for two weeks and
ended up being bamboozled for over two
years with this absolute draconian
totalitarian nonsense we're now
artificial intelligence facial
recognition technology is being used to
track trace and database almost every
single move they make like recently
implemented in south korea like
implemented and all the other nations
that were formerly democratic that are
becoming more despotic by the day it's
crazy what's happening out there and uh
that's why i think we also need to
acknowledge that there's a lot of
protest against it there's been so many
movements there's been so many
demonstrations there have been so many
gatherings from all over the world from
peru to georgia to the czech republic
spain argentina austria germany france
we have seen a huge huge number of
people come together and say enough is
enough i'm sick of this and for um you
know very surprisingly well not for me
but for people the normies out there the
corporate media is not talking about it
at all not even mentioning any of these
mass movements that are coming together
unorganized what are they doing they're
they're coordinating with the by the
administration behind closed doors to
spin how bad the economy is doing and
it's working like to a certain degree a
bunch of articles popped up right after
that where they were like the economy is
actually good five cents less for gas
this is awesome this is great
yeah
literally pennies thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 00 pm
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time